we have breaking news the new york
federal reserve
just came out with revised inflation
expectations what are we thinking
the new york federal reserve now sees
inflation
still above five percent one year from
today
they believe three years from today on a
percent piece it'll be over four percent
and a series high with large expected
price rises in food rent and medical
costs
so basically everything you spend money
on is gonna go up
here's the craziest part
if inflation is still above five percent
a year from now that's five percent
above
where it is today which is five percent
above where it was a year ago yeah
we now are in compounding territory
ladies and gentlemen put on your helmet
strap in your seat belts do not talk
while the pilot takes off because we are
gonna start compounding at a rate that
you cannot imagine yeah the one thing
that that people don't talk about enough
is that like the price increases aren't
going anywhere the inflation when it
moves back down to two percent those
price increases that all these people
made to combat all this inflation and
all the
uh kind of the supply chain effects
those aren't going anywhere so
we see five percent four percent
what do they want to take out i'm sure
we'll be taking out food rent medical
calls soon
when we report the official numbers
but ultimately yeah those price
increases aren't going anywhere so your
dollar you're losing your purchasing
power uh daily now you're it's just
getting worse and worse and worse and
we've seen people are flocking to
inflation hedge assets whether it's
bitcoin or something else uh gold
doesn't really seem to be uh the thing
that's down seven percent over the last
year yeah that that uh people are
choosing but real estate other uh kind
of digital assets and stuff like that
people are clearly choosing to exit the
us dollar and look for assets that are
going can protect their purchasing power
are a store of value and have
appreciated over time i think that'll
continue to happen over the next year
obviously with numbers like this being
thrown around you know what worries me
is if this is their expectation they're
probably gonna miss on expectations and
just blow past it we might see eight
percent in a year
i mean they were wrong every other time
and it's always it's always they're
wrong in their favor they're like oh we
were expecting this and then it actually
was a lot more yeah so if they're
expecting 5.2 4 in three years is
is not a crazy expectation i don't think
but 5.2 percent is is wild like we said
uh pomboys motors with the economic
predictions over here people on twitter
have been saying this stuff for a year
now and the federal reserve i don't know
if whether they knew it was happening
and they just didn't want to say it or
if they later came to that conclusion uh
but now they're saying the stuff that
people thought uh everyone was crazy on
twitter for saying right like people
have been beating the drum on this for
12 to 18 months now saying that this is
what was happening this is what was
going to happen over the next few years
uh in food rent uh medical costs
everything associated with kind of the
inflation measures but this is clear
that it's happening they didn't talk
about it before they actually combated
and said not to worry and now they're
admitting it so good run them for
admitting it but ultimately the people
on twitter were right we should
congratulate them on changing their
minds but it's not even just the people
on twitter
bitcoiners understand the us economy
better than wall street i've been saying
this literally for over a year now this
was so obvious go back check the
receipts last year inflation's not going
to happen don't worry about it we have
no concerns bitcoiners were up in arms
yelling and screaming about it
then it became the story of its
transitory we are now talking about
compounding inflation annually a four to
five percent for half a decade you
will not survive financially if you
simply work an hourly job and save
dollars
get out of your hourly job because
they're not going to go ahead and
increase your pay enough to keep up with
it they're going to pay you less and
less and less year after year after year
for the coming years
and two is if you're a saver
you're screwed
you have to learn to invest
i don't care what assets you invest in i
don't care if you like equities real
estate uh commodities crypto whatever
don't buy gold
and don't buy bonds
but other than that go figure out and
learn how to invest because you are
going to get screwed we are watching in
real time
food rent and medical costs have are
going to have quote large expected price
rises the new york federal reserve this
is not somebody on twitter the new york
federal reserve is saying this the three
main things that you spend money on are
going to have large expected price rises
they don't put large in there unless
they mean large and on top of that
what we are watching is businesses that
are struggling more and more
which means that they have to
do things to try to get more employees
to work at their business
this is incredible i mean
this is nuts see last month's cpi
numbers are being released tomorrow too
cpi expectation august 2021
uh
unless they actually did 5.6
3.9
[Laughter]
now this is not the official this is
like one i'm taking one i'm taking bets
on if they're correct or not
yeah this is uh one group um somebody
said 3.9 is like saying the new york
jets will in the super bowl
i don't make the rules they said it hey
guys bang bang thanks so much for
watching the best business show today
and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account
software.compomp and make sure you come
back and watch more of the best business
show we're going to build the biggest
business show in the world and we need
your help
[Music]